we talk some football news from around
the league right now with a man who
represents our Honda inside a report as
well as Sports Illustrated with a fresh
mm QB good to see you Albert 11 training
camps you've been tuned that's right 12
teams 11 training camps I'll probably
wind up I want to get close to 20 well
you're going Arizona today soon as
you're done here you're heading in the
epitaphs the fort right around the
corner LA actually taking us right ok so
you were in Dallas yesterday yep what's
the latest with Zeek what are you
hearing uh so I think that the Cowboys
are willing to pay him close to or more
than Todd Gurley like they're willing to
replicate the contract what they're not
willing to do is blow up the market the
way the girl in contract blew up the
market last year and I think with all
these guys it's complicated but with all
these guys with dak they're willing to
go over 30 with Amar'e I think they're
willing to pay him in the top five at
his position and with Zeke I think
they're willing to go where the Rams
went would talk Gurley the thing is
they've done such a good track good job
drafting there are other guys they've
got to take care of too Byron Jones has
turned into a pretty good corner Jaylon
Smith great story at linebacker you know
Stephen Jones told me yesterday
this is his deep a team as he's had
since the 90s and I'm not by the way I
would back it back that up yeah normally
we always joke about the hyperbole from
the Jones family certainly last year
when they were talking about how close
they were to the Rams offense and a lot
of people like really funny you know
Tavon Austin is the only thing that you
could possibly replicate it they're
there they're not there they're I think
they're Super Bowl worthy if everybody's
happy and paid and ready and healthy and
and his whole point was we're not trying
to save money for the franchise he's
like we want to take care of everybody
and at the same time he acknowledged
it's not Zeke's job or DAX job or a
mary's job to manage our cap and so
that's sort of the hard thing I think
right now they view all these guys and
in Zeke's issue I think was that he's
not in the contract year because they
got the fifth year option I'm the way
Amar'e or doc are so Zeke was sort of
number three in the list and Zeke
holding out him trying to push number
one on the list and so I think ideally
you'd like to get the quarterback done
first because it's the biggest piece of
the puzzle is gonna be the biggest
contract but I think right now a month
out from the season they still view this
as part of the process
I think they should give a quarterback
first
because as you say is important crucial
but he's also there yeah so you know if
you're gonna you know that that's
something you need to do to at some
point just a little bit all the rest of
your team like if you want to talk
Turkey you got to be in here that said
Zeke is that important they've got it
they have to pay me I have to get him in
week one
for the Giants with the Redskins right
behind him those are two crucial games
if you want to win your division
sometimes I think it matters which order
you pay guys in right look because the
locker room is paying attention to who
you're paying and this is where I think
some of Zeke's off field stuff comes
into play of course where I think the
locker room pays attention to that stuff
I remember talking to Scott McLuhan
about this when he was with the Redskins
and you know Trent Williams had had some
issues they intentionally paid Ryan
Kerrigan first because they want to send
that message to the locker room and I
think that's something that could come
into play here too is dak has done
everything right ever since he got into
the pros he's done absolutely everything
right been an a-plus leader for them and
so maybe it makes sense for them with a
young locker room we're gonna send the
message of paying dak and then we can
take care of everybody else plus I think
it makes it easier to pay everybody else
when you know what that biggest piece of
the puzzle looks like so you think all
three are taken care of by the time they
break camp in Oxnard in a couple weeks
or they're all three are taken care of
by the time week 1 starts I all part I
don't think that I don't think the Amari
Cooper negotiation is as active as the
other two okay I mean there's a good
chance one or both of dak and Zeke get
done I'd be a little more surprise of
Amari Cooper gets done I think their
intention is to keep him long term the
negotiation just hasn't been as active I
got to get both don't think they have to
get deck anzi I mean because Zeke's not
coming back from Cabo without a deal
although although you know I mentioned
on Friday's show the television audience
missed it because we were just radial
only that the reason why maybe the
Joneses are sitting back in any way
shape or form period is that their
leverage swings back more in Dallas this
way as Zeke gets closer to missing an
actual paycheck in Week one right
there's there's no question about that
the other thing I think you have to pay
attention to here I like if you're Zeke
right think about it this way if the
Rams have to pay Todd Gurley now right
if the Rams and girl he decided table
things last summer say it didn't work
out
and now we have all the information now
like we have all that information now
what happens with this need you think
they Pam so Zeke's looking at that and
saying I like I don't know if I can risk
going back out there you know just
because the weight players in my
position are paid and because of what I
just saw with another premier player in
my position and the flip side of that is
you know the Cowboys I think want to
build some protections into the contract
so those are all things they've got to
work through I'm with you I think the
real sort of tension point is week one
you know III don't think we're there yet
and I think when we get closer to the
start of the season that's when you
start to see okay like this is the
Cowboys real best offer and this is how
far Zeke is really willing to come down
our abrir from the mm QB joining me here
on the Rich Eisen showing the Honda
inside a report so you stopped by the
Chargers what's the conversation about
Melvin Gordon down with the Chargers and
there I they're dug in I mean they made
him they made him an offer they think
it's a fair offer it's right around 10
million a year it's I would say with
inflation it's probably similar to what
Devonta Freeman got in Atlanta last year
I Melvin Gordon I'll obviously sees
himself as a better player than that and
I think it's sort of one of those where
it's like caught in the complication
where you've got this huge gap between
what Todd Gurley got and then like what
levy I'm Bell wanted but failed to get
and then there's what everybody else has
been getting you know and so the Gurley
contract became such an outlier oh now
you've got this huge gap it's a little
bit like a few years ago Calvin Johnson
had a contract that was way bigger than
any of the receiver and so we were just
like this middle ground that teams had a
lot of heart they had a hard time like
slotting there their receivers into with
Melvin Gordon they think they feel like
they've got a fair offer out there to
him you know but I think the girly thing
the girl in contract especially cuz girl
he's in the same draft classism kind of
poisons it a little bit oh it's amazing
don't the girly contract really screwed
with a lot of other people yeah I mean
Le'Veon Bell was here and on the show
and our number two clearly you know saw
that and had an issue with the worst
dealers were even approaching him amen
obviously Zeke mm-hmm obviously Gordon
so it's smart that the Rams went ahead
and if they can afford it went ahead and
did
right if they if they ascribe that much
value to - I mean like look I think
girly-girly to me was this is like girly
and Zeke I anchor in like almost a
different category than Belle not that
they're that much better players in
Belle but their teams are still relying
on them and I think so much of dak being
able to contribute at a young age and
Goths Renaissance like those two things
I think we're so dependent on the on the
back and that gave those players
leverage you know and so I think in the
RAM situation they got to a Super Bowl
in large part because of what Todd
Gurley did from September to November
and what he did to revitalize the
franchise and so I don't think it's a
mistake to app a guy like that because
you're getting so much mileage out of
him who cares what everybody else makes
you got so much mileage out of the guy
he was the offensive player of the year
for ya and you know you sign him early
so you know what that means you're gonna
get to the non-guaranteed years a little
earlier and so you're gonna have some
more flexibility a little earlier
earlier than you might otherwise well
and before we move to the quarterbacks
what about Gurley what what in the hell
happened to his knee last year and then
and then what what can we expect of him
this year what did you hear when you saw
the RAM it was interesting because I
talked to a couple of teams before I
went there and you know we were just you
know you just talked about different
things going on in league and girl his
name would come up what I found pretty
consistently was most teams had what
they'd call longevity grade on Gurley
coming out of Georgia and this is sort
of similar and not as serious a case but
sort of similar I remember miles Jack
coming out a couple years ago to the
second round the question is like how
long he's gonna last right it's like is
this a one contract guy and that was the
question what Gurley coming out and so
you know I think it's something that's
sort of hovered over his career two
years ago like you remember Jeff
Fisher's last year there wasn't a great
year for Todd Gurley they really felt
like that year he sort of lacked
confidence in the scheme like maybe he
was dealing with you you think when he
called it a high school often seems like
some weird stuff going on there right
and I and like I think a big part of
girls game is how decisive he runs how
hard he runs all that and you know you
just sort of grew that repeat this
reputation that year I was like when he
really doesn't trust something like all
of a sudden he turns into a different
player and the rams felt like that was
part of the
equation yeah he was hurting last year
he wasn't trusting me but there was like
maybe a little bit of a trust issue
there and so getting him back to the
point where he's the same confident
player again I think is a big deal for
the right okay so do we expect him to at
least them attempt to make him the bail
Cowan obviously I'm asking this infused
with a lot of interested fantasy
observers as well like what sort of I
think they're in platoon or more like I
just III I think they're going I think
the goal now is to get the most out of
him and I'm not sure that they believe
getting the most out of him anymore
means giving him the ball 25 times a
game it's ember or not - right III and I
think that you know look they match on
Malcolm Brown that was a low not there's
not a ton of money there but they
matched on a restricted free agent
running back Malcolm Brown who signed an
offer sheet with the line so he's back
they draft Darryl Henderson who they
love and this was you know more a case
of them it wasn't drafting a position
they just like the player that much like
Sean McVeigh liked that player that much
said that's a guy who totally fits what
we do and so I think because they've got
Brownback and now they they bring in
Darryl Henderson who they can do
different things with out of the
backfield and we'll be like sort of a
fun weapon for Sean WEP for Shah McVeigh
to have they've now got the flexibility
to execute I think more of a platoon
with Todd Gurley which ultimately allow
him to get more out of Gurley long-term
mm QB senior reporter Albert Puryear
here in the Honda inside a report let's
get to the quarterback center
conversation you had with Phillip Rivers
the floor is yours what happened it was
really interesting because I think I've
had these conversations within the last
couple of years and he always said I
remember him saying to me that last year
he's like oh you know Drew and Tom they
talked about playing 2:45 you can have
that I don't want that right
and so he said I probably he's
consistently said I probably have a
handful of years left and so now it was
well I'm sort of year-to-year now he's
in the last year of his contract so
that's a question to me what was most
interesting was his long-term goal which
was I'm not one of these guys who's
scared of being done playing I'm excited
about what I'm gonna do next I'm gonna
coach high school football and I want to
coach my son so while he was saying he
was year-to-year yes he was like my
older soul his son gunner hmm is a fifth
grade quarterback right now
fifth grade fifth grade quarterback okay
so we're talking four more years anyway
I mean right that means he would play to
celebrate Tom Brady's current age right
he so he but not to forty five like
Brady and Tom have talked about like so
he sort of put a timeline on himself
there and he said and I don't want to be
hustlin out to go coach him either like
I want to like have a natural retirement
and then just kind of get into coaching
and coach my kid and because you know
his his dad was a high school football
coach his high school football coach and
that's great and so he wants to give his
kid the experience that he had growing
up I thought it was a really cool thing
because you know I think with a lot of
these guys I think if I think of Brady's
being being honest with you there's a
little fear there of what's next cuz he
loves what he does so much and he's so
competitive and all that right and I
think with a lot of athletes the way it
is it was kind of cool to talk to
Phillip Rivers saying no I know exactly
what I'm gonna do but he knows what his
offense is gonna look like like he and
his brother have talked about how well
we're gonna be a mix of what we did with
Norv and what we what we're doing now
he's a coach what he was it coach yeah
and so he has like this whole offense
laid out that he's gonna run in the high
school the high school level and yeah
his son I mean I like I guess we can
talk to the people of Michigan the
people in Ohio State now
Gunnar rivers I think will be class of
2027 give him some sort of early
recognition right now yeah Lane Kiffin
right so okay well break down Brady's
contract for me Albert yeah wait what is
that I I would just tell you like I so
the way you want to look at this it
would have cost them seventy million
dollars to tag them twice over the next
two years so that's the new money in the
deal they give him an eight million
dollar raise now and then that eight
million dollars comes out of the next
two years so instead of having to tag
him in 2020 and 2021 they've got these
non-guaranteed years there that all I
think the way it was explained to me
it's going to allow both teams to make a
conscious decision each year on how they
want to go forward and I think that
they're sort of leaning on the Brady
crafts relationship here knowing like
we'll be able to work this out one way
or another and I know it sounds like oh
well it's year-to-year and like this
like the doom is looming over this whole
thing
I haven't gotten the census that way at
all it's more just like look if someone
changes their mind
we've got flexibility here quarter and
it also appears to be the first instance
of we found somebody who is not being
gotten rid of before the end of his
usefulness that they've always that's
been always a hallmark of the Patriot
way if you will right is to make sure
that you're moving on before before the
circumstances force it right yeah and
and what's so interesting about it to me
is like we all look at like I think
everybody like last year was looking for
the far the Peyton Manning like sort of
fall off a cliff where you can see it
right well I think what the pages of
repair for is like what if this is John
Elway you know where John Elway in 96 97
98 was still a good player but maybe it
wasn't the guy he was an 88 where he
could carry a whole team right or how
about this we've never seen this before
that there is no comparison to what
we're seeing right this is a 42 year old
guy freshly on Saturday turning 42 yeah
same day that my wife had a birthday
that and Marley be that we have never
seen a 42 year old president and that
there will be a 43 year old guy getting
set for preseason action looking for a
new deal that you have to pay because of
what the 42 year old guy looked like and
then the 44 year old guy will sit there
and go you know what we either just won
a Super Bowl or made it as far as the
AFC Championship game and I just you
know I think I want to keep playing like
that we won't see that precipitous fall
off with a deep throw or anything like
yeah that we have never seen anything
spa scible yeah right and we don't and
we don't know this thing but we didn't
know if Favre we didn't know what
Manning Manning it happened do you know
like me but I think he just assumed it
was gonna happen at least at some point
with that guy I mean with Brady with
Brady I mean like I'm past the point
yeah I'm past the point I passed that I
passed the point of like waiting for the
bottom to drop out like I think at the
like I think the Elway scenario is more
likely right look I think the Elway
scenario is more likely
or maybe you start to see like maybe he
looks a little different but I just
think like I don't know I just think he
has a way of figuring it out like he'll
figure like if he loses a little arm
strength I think he'll figure it out
you know I think you'll figure out how
to play a little differently and I think
what's interesting is you see the way
the team is built differently now
everybody is getting smaller right like
the spread offense is now you got two
hundred twenty pound linebackers out
there 250 pound defensive ends well what
would be an efficiency P the
inefficiency would be no one's got size
or girth up front anymore so what do you
do you do with the Patriots did last
year you draft the 220 pen running back
in the first round you have a fullback
on the roster and you come out with two
tight ends and two running backs and win
the Super Bowl out of that formation and
in a way like Belichick being able to
play that inefficiency right plays right
into being able to support Brady because
if you're playing offense that way it
makes it a little bit easier to support
an older quarterbacks like what Terrell
Davis did for John Elway years ago
before I let you go Albert Breer the
best team you've seen a third of the
league best deepest it look everybody
looks great now everybody feels like
they got a 12 win season in them I
understand that yeah but in terms of
roster size deep sensibility in the
locker room yeah a coaching staff but of
the 11 teams that you've eyeballed which
would you say you know what that's the
one that I think is the Saints I just
like in it and part of its gonna depend
on the same thing the Patriots depending
on which is an older quarterback keeping
his right keeping his game where it
needs to be but that Saints team die
like I don't think that they've got a
whole look I don't think there's a hole
in that roster they're very strong and
deep at corner they're strong and deep
on the offensive line those are two
areas where a lot of teams have problems
and are very very important in the NFL
today and I just you know I look at the
receiver group around around Drew Brees
what Jared cooks gonna be able to do
right Michael Thomas what he's become
Alvin Kamara the the the weapon out of
the backfield they've done such a nice
job and I think that this isn't a little
bit of an under played story they've
drafted so well the last three or four
years and the roster now is in such good
shape and I think it's capable of put it
this way like when I sat down with Sean
Payton and Drew Brees the other day
I got the feeling that they feel like
this team is better than the 2009 team
that won the Superbowl and it's really
gonna be up to them to get the team that
where it needs to be but they've been
knocking on the door man they've been
right there and losing the way they did
the last two years the players I know
yeah I mean lightning struck twice the
last two times yeah and plus they've got
a coaching staff with a you know headed
up by a guy who's won it before and
there's no turnover you're right they
may have zero holes when the guy I don't
I I look when I was out there I mean so
they lose max Unger
right there their center great Center
for Seattle for all those years
Erik McCoy looks great as a rookie at
that position opposite Marshawn
Lattimore they've been looking for a
corner Eli Apple who didn't have his
option exercise right has actually
looked pretty good in camp they've got
depth you know in the second area which
you need in today's NFL it's just it's
it's one of these teams it's just very
balanced across the board so as long as
Drew Brees can continue to be Drew Brees
which again like now that I guess it's
not unprecedented more there's one
precedent for it it's Brady but you know
freeze can be Brees at 40 years old
I think the Saints have a chance to be
right back where they've been the last
two years right at the doorstep I just
realize this I'm sure the Saints have
the most Ohio State players on the
roster of NFL Draft well good stock ask
him the poll question before we send him
up the road to LAX he can get his flight
to Cardinals camp later on today yeah
Albert which quarterback would you want
for the next three years Brady breeze
rivers Roethlisberger Brady Brees next
three years now that Brees now that
Brady's supposedly under Brady like I
just I like all the other guys so the
other guys are good players yeah it's
gotta be Brady Brady 43% right now he's
away and that puts him at what 44 was
the third year he would be he would go
through his entire third year at it as a
44 year old man okay yeah cuz this one
brings him right up to 45th birthday
which is actually his what he said is
his goal that's his goal yeah all of us
here at the Rich Eisen show are
genuinely concerned we're sending you
out of here with sunscreen Albert are
you are you applying sunscreen I don't
screen underneath says you don't know
you know it's my greatest skills my
ability to tan I told you guys only one
day one day the tide will turn we're
genuinely concerned for you I mean you
are a ridiculous shade of tan right now
it's just a mix of it's it's in a good
way I mean I guess you know you're good
at Southern California the grand
Midwestern camps that you visited a
little bit of New Orleans a lot of Sun
we won't give it to you you just smash
it into pieces so you can get your
clicks on out Albert Breer and also
Albert underscore Breer on instagram
great stuff as always and you can go
check out mmq be calm because it's not
the mmq be right vmm qubit is the mmq be
calm okay cuz I make sure I want to make
sure it's the MQB calm cuz when you go
to another one it's completely different
never forget thee never forget thee I
just walked into that one
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app